[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au musée
grataloup qui va bientôt ouvrir ses
portes à chevreuse voici le sommaire un
musée consacré à l'art contemporain en
vallée de chevreuse le musée grattage
ouvrira ses portes samedi 12 mars dans
la chapelle du prieuré saint saturnin à
chevreuse la présidente de l'association
les amis du musée grataloup et épouse de
l'artiste nous présente ses oeuvres à 25
ans l'artiste versaillaise rome s'est
elle dévoile son premier ep elle nous
présente également son univers et ses
derniers clips et enfin c'est le retour
du festival festi bouche du 12 au 23
mars au théâtre du grenier à bougival
quatre spectacles pour enfants sont
programmés
je me trouve dans la chapelle du prieuré
saint saturnin à chevreuse et c'est ici
que se situe le musée grataloup il faut
ouvrir ses portes samedi 12 mars un
projet culturel qu'il dévoile le genre
et les oeuvres de l'artiste peintre guy
rachel grataloup décédé en janvier
dernier que ce musée est le seul le
dédié à la peinture contemporaine en
vallée de chevreuse me ménage séné de
beaupré bonjour bonjour à vous êtes donc
la présidente de l'association les amis
du musée grataloup et les pousses de
l'artiste si ce lieu où nous sommes a
été choisi pour accueillir le travail de
grataloup ce n'est pas dû au hasard en
2011 il a conçu trois vitraux
contemporains de cette chapelle c'est ça
oui tout à fait d'ailleurs c'était
effectivement bien avant la création de
l'association des amis du musée
grataloup puisqu'en fait c'est une
association relativement récente qui est
le fruit d'une collaboration avec la
mairie de chevreuse les vitraux ont été
créés en collaboration avec les ateliers
loirat sharks sont de très grands
maîtres verriers
incontournable de la rénovation des
vitraux également pour les vitraux la
création des vitres ou en art
contemporain et ça a été donc créé alors
que la rénovation de la chapelle la
chapelle était dans un piteux état en
2011 avant sa rénovation d'ailleurs
elles avaient été fermées parce qu'elle
menaçait de s'écrouler enfin en grande
partie donc en fait est là il ya eu un
grand chantier lancé en 2011 et c'est à
cette occasion que le maire de la ville
a demandé à agra talent ou de créer des
vitraux pour cette chapelle est donc ce
qui nous vaut donc ces magnifiques
vitraux donc trois vitraux le pommier en
face m donc on est vraiment dont je
dirais l'origine de l'homme et puis bien
sûr le sablier qui en fait symbole du
temps qui nous caractérise sur la terre
alors 9,2 grâce à lure est immense il a
débuté sa carrière à l'âge de 12 ans on
lui compte des milliers de tableaux
faisant cruellement on ne peut pas les
compter je n'ai pas compté mais oui oui
vraiment de milliers je pense et
justement alors quel style de peinture
ou courants artistiques le caractérise
finalement et bien justement c'est sa
particularité parce qu'il n'appartient à
aucun courant il a créé sa propre
peinture il a créé son style qui lui
appartient qui est absolument unique
lorsque vous regardez une oeuvre de
grataloup vous avez besoin de la voir
une seule fois si vous revoyez d'autres
perdu au milieu d'autres vous saurez que
cette ingrate à luceau voir la signature
certaines collections de l'artiste sont
exposées de manière plutôt originale ici
dans ce musée eh bien oui parce qu'en
fait c'était je dirais un peu un pari
d'abord de conserver la pureté des lieux
donc on n'a pas voulu non plus
surchargées les murs en toile donc sous
chaque toile à travers un petit flash
code on peut accéder aux commentaires
qui donne des clés de compréhension par
rapport aux oeuvres on a également la
possibilité à travers ce moniteur de
diffuser des films où on peut entendre
le peintre on peut même le voir
travailler donc ça c'est c'est quand
même formidable parce que ça donne
proximité justement avec le pagne qui
n'est plus aujourd'hui pour nous le
faire partager et puis on a ce
merveilleux son et lumière qui nous
permet de partager d'autres oeuvres qui
ne sont pas exposées sur les murs
entoure une quinzaine en tout cas
d'oeuvres donc sur les murs grand format
dans sont installés oui le musée
accueillera deux expositions par an et
la première s'appelle sel et des regards
des elfes le farfadet ou encore fait ces
personnages que l'on aime être de la
nature ou encore esprits de la nature
sont présents sur beaucoup de toiles de
l'artiste grataloup sur ce tableau c'est
l'esprit de l'air qui est dévoilée et
l'esprit de l'air et bien c'est ce
personnage qui est recouvert de feuilles
d'or 22 carats qui part finalement et
qui est libre qui sort de cette matière
qu'on voit sur la partie droite en bas
de la toile pour pour s'envoler vers
l'ère quoi et finalement ça c'est le
symbole en fête de la liberté profonde
de l'être humain qui choisit finalement
son destin l'exposition ciel et terre
est à découvrir au musée grataloup qui
va ouvrir ses portes samedi 12 mars
l'artiste décédé depuis peu avait choisi
l'emplacement de ces douze toiles qui
représente la relation de l'homme au
ciel finalement ça nous ramène à notre
humilité d'êtres humains et finalement
c'est ce qu'il s'était sa recherche en
fait métaphysique principalement et
finalement ça colle parfaitement au sens
profond de son travail cet autre tableau
fait partie de la série promesses d'aidé
m sur la thématique des fleurs et du yin
et du yang et vous voyez sur cette toile
ce qui est intéressant de voir à quel
point d'ailleurs grataloup était
quelqu'un et qui travaillait avec toutes
les techniques possibles et imaginables
aille beaucoup de sable vous voyez sur
la partie droite toute la partie noire
qui comme de la sculpture c'est avec du
sable d'alcool
r on retrouve beaucoup beaucoup
l'utilisation du sable collé comme de la
sculpture dans ses toiles grands
coloristes grataloup travaillez beaucoup
avec l'or et le bleu cette exposition
est visible jusqu'au 30 septembre milena
chesnais de beaupré il n'y aura pas que
le travail en deux grataloup qui sera
exposée le but de cet établissement est
aussi de faire découvrir aux visiteurs
des artistes contemporains exactement
c'est l'objectif du musée c'est rendre
accessible au plus grand nombre l'art
contemporain parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'apprend pas vraiment à
l'école d'art contemporain on sait pas
trop ce que c'est et c'est ce lieu
absolument magique va nous permettre de
découvrir d'autres artistes donc pour
cela l'association a conclu un
partenariat avec le château de l'accueil
qui se trouvent en normandie est un lieu
centre d'art très important qui
accueille depuis des années voire
plusieurs générations les plus grands
artistes de l'art contemporain et grâce
à ce partenariat et en particulier marie
laure pas pierre que je remercie tous
les jours nous allons pouvoir avoir
accès directement à ces artistes qui
parfois sont amis et ont été remis de
grataloup une sauce maison parfois
exposés ensemble d'ailleurs parce que
c'est toute cette même génération que
nous allons exposer et nous allons
pouvoir de façon très simple
présenter l'histoire de l'art compte or
un dans ce lieu merveilleux merci il est
vrai et nous allons désormais si vous le
voulez bien partir dans la maison
atelier qui se situe à 5 minutes c'est
çà de là avec plaisir
[Musique]
alors voilà l'atelier ok oui c'est très
me la passer un nombre d'heures
incalculables dans sa vie
alors c'est en 1989 que grataloup
installe sa maison-atelier ici à
chevreuse cette maison déjà en quoi elle
est atypique et bien écoutez d'abord
elle a été construite par un ami de
grataloup qui est à la fois un grand
collectionneur et qui était son premier
collectionneur a d'ailleurs très jeune
et c'est un ami qui est architecte et
membre de l'académie des architectures
c'est un immense architectes qui
s'appelle de nice lawn et cette amitié
d'ailleurs perdure enfin aperture et
jusque dans les derniers moments de
grâce à doute puisque vraiment on peut
dire qu'il l'accompagné jusqu'au bout et
il a construite cette maison pour son
ami pour sa peinture pour la lumière qui
était présente à travers la peinture et
on retrouve d'ailleurs dans cette maison
c'est puits de lumière en fait le toit
et transparent on entend les éléments on
entend la pluie le vent la neige et
c'est une maison en fait dans lequel il
se sentait immensément bien cet été son
refuge s'il a conçu des milliers
d'oeuvres il pouvait passer des journées
entières atteindre oui il avait en fait
un espèce de rythme extrêmement organisé
d'ailleurs grataloup pour lui la valeur
absolue c'était le travail est gratuite
est un artiste touche-à-tout finalement
et de nombreuses oeuvres sont visibles
au delà de chevreuse mêmes d'île de
france alors bien évidemment l'oeuvre
c'est la peinture mais c'est également
l'art urbain l'art urbain donc il a
on qu'on appelle parfois aussi art
monumental alors il ya une oeuvre très
connu que tout le monde évidemment que
tout le monde côtoie c'est sur
l'esplanade de la défense est une grande
tour d'aération qui s'appelle les trois
armes très connu et qui a représenté
d'ailleurs un travail incroyable
puisqu'il il a fait le dessin à
l'échelle 1 donc quand vous imaginez
c'est est décédé millions de tesselles
de mosaïques et il a fait ça donc à
l'échelle en dansant dans un grand
atelier d'ailleurs de l'école normale
supérieure de cachan où il était
directeur
merci beaucoup en tout cas un millénaire
je n'avais ouvrait d'ailleurs qu'on peut
dire milena grataloup et howie parce que
je suis avant tout grataloup milena de
lettres beaupré c'est mon nom de jeune
fille et j'adore beaucoup mon nom de
jeune fille mais avant tout je me sens
la femme du pain que je suis milena
grataloup merci beaucoup alors milena
grade avec notre invité merci aussi
musique à présent à versailles la jeune
artiste rome s'est elle dévoile l'un de
ses premiers ep intitulé aperçu un avant
goût de son univers entre peuples et
musiques françaises elle nous dévoile
aussi l'un de ses derniers clips
regarder je perds ce sont
[Musique]
ce soir c'est le titre de cette chanson
composée et interprétée par la jeune
artiste rome s'est elle a 25 ans cette
versailles et se produit toutes les deux
semaines au café de la pêche à
versailles elle a fait ses études au
conservatoire de musique de la ville
j'ai commencé avec la flûte à bec qui a
été mon premier instrument et ensuite
je me suis un autodidacte je me suis
intéressé au piano et à la guitare
et j'ai fait un an de saxophone au
conservatoire de viroflay rome s'est
elle a commencé à écrire et composer des
chansons à 14 ans en avril dernier elle
sort son premier ep intitulé aperçu je
voulais vraiment faire de la musique ma
vie et on travaille enfin être vraiment
dedans donc j'ai décidé de faire noter
pour montrer un peu ce que je pouvais
faire penser vraiment une palette de
cinq titres différents qui ont été
écrits sur six en quoi marcher dans les
rues je crois que je suis père du petit
garçon avec moi l'artiste versaillais
s'est tourné vers la pop et la variété
française avec quelques accords jazz il
raconte nous pvq qu'on a entre 14 et 20
ans à peu près les sentiments qu'on peut
avoir les difficultés qu'on rencontre
les concepts cinq titres qui parlent de
son vécu le clip de la chanson sublime
et sort dans quelques semaines si vous
aimer cette musique qui parle vraiment
de de tout ce qu'on a autour de nous qui
est des conditions des conditionnements
qu'on a on nous oblige à voir et qui
peuvent nous mettre certains complexes
de certains vins qui nous empêche de se
sentir fort bien avec nous mêmes et
qu'ils vont mettre des stops sur ce
qu'on voudrait être en 2020 de robes
celle des projets plein la tête avec
notamment la sortie de son deuxième ep
le festival jeune public festiblues
revient pour une quatrième édition au
théâtre du grenier à bougival quatre
spectacles pour enfants seront
programmées un jury constitué d'enfants
lui aussi pourra émettre des avis sur
les représentations
sensibiliser les enfants au spectacle
vivant et les rendre acteurs de ce qu'il
voit c'est ce que propose le festival
festi bouge à bougival pendant une
semaine et demi quatre rendez vous
seront proposés aux enfants dont deux
bilingues français-anglais au programme
théâtre et comédies musicales ça les
aide à grandir c'est à dire que dans
tous les spectacles bien sûr on sort du
quotidien on sort de la vie tous les
jours mais ça nous ramène à la vie de
tous les jours c'est à dire souvent ce
sont des spectacles qui sont en lien
avec un rite initiatique cela les aide à
vivre leurs émotions un jury d'enfants
se rassemblera après chaque
représentation pour parler de la
direction de comédiens des décors de la
mise en scène ou encore de la musique ça
jury constitué d'enfants de différents
âges ce qui veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
toujours la même grille de perception
grille de lecture et c'est intéressant
parce qu'en plus c'est sur des
spectacles qui sont complètement
différents donc l'idée c'est pas
tellement de créer un palmarès mais
c'est plus créer un petit peu un
parcours de spectateurs l'école du
spectateur les enfants vont devoir
trouver les forces de chaque pièce et
par là qu'on perd peut pas la
comparaison on va aussi faire émerger
justement la qualité de chacune de ces
pièces le festival débutera le 12 mars
avec un premier spectacle de théâtre
bilingue aliens par la compagnie qu à
l'aco si votre enfant a entre 6 et 12
ans et souhaite constituer le jury vous
avez jusqu'au jeudi 10 mars pour
proposer sa candidature
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez-vous à
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yves binois bonne soirée sur
télé 78
[Musique]